Wir könnten nicht ohne die Galerie bleiben
Es war seine Welt, mein Vater wollte ihn
tun, weil er nicht darüber gesprochen hat
Fortsetzung für mich war ich auch ein
Baby, was könnte ich verstehen, sagt er
er versuchte mir alles ein wenig zu erklären
wie alle Vereinbarungen zwischen den
drei Kinder von mythischen Diven wie dir
in Verbindung gebracht
das heißt, jeder brachte die Beine zum Umdenken
es geht, ich sage nicht, alles geht seine eigenen Grundlagen
Ich fühle es einfach, ich fühle es präsent
so nach einer Weile tca Video dazu, dass
man sieht es nicht aber schlachten fühlt man ja
Ich am Anfang, als ich hier ankam
Ich dachte, ich bringe es zur Sprache
Familie, weil meine Kinder früher dort waren
erwachsen werden und sie wollten nicht kommen
Sie sagten, dass ihr Sizilien
Momentan lassen sie es nicht so, wie es ist
Zustand
das ist okay, auch wenn alles dort angefangen hat
Familie, die da runtergeht und die Sonne vermisst
Ich vermisse einen anderen meiner Freunde
Freunde, um das Meer zu jagen
Nehmen wir an, die Sizilianer betreten hier Kreuzungen
der Gesundheit
die Tür, wie er sagte, es gibt einige
Dinge, die Sie von hier bringen
auch wenn du es nicht von mir willst, würden sie es sein
für immer hier bleiben
dieses Angebot, das nicht sein konnte
Handeln, weil eine Familie mit tausend
Euro im Monat kann nur ein Vater nicht
ertrage es also unbedingt jetzt oder
dass ich auf Baustellen herumlaufe 24 25 Jahre alt bin und bin
müde vom Drehen und dann hoffe ich
früh in Rente gehen, aber nicht für
etwas zu entfernen, sagt mindestens einer bova
nach Hause gehen
nein, nicht mehr arbeiten, um nicht zu hören
sagt diese Baustelle endet jetzt wo ich hingehe
vielleicht bleiben sie zu hause vielleicht sind sie das nicht
Sie arbeiten meine Kinder dann, wenn ich sie gebe
nur danach suche ich
Schauen Sie sich die Galerie an wie Zigaretten
wie eine Droge
Galerie 2 tritt als Scherz ein
drinnen dann gehst du nicht so viel raus e
Sicher ist so viel gefährlich, denn wenn Sie
Ich habe Sie nicht alle glatte Hinweise nicht gefunden
du verletzt nicht einmal einen Finger einen Finger nicht
du tust es
aber wenn es dich erwischt, wirst du verletzt, aber da
aber ich achte darauf, dass du gehst
lass uns das Leder
und dann fühlte er das Unglaubliche daran
als ich diese Worte sagte
aber es war nie stationär immer im arbeiten
Erinnerung an seinen todmüden Kämpfer
Soldat wäre von dieser Seite die Werke
war leise
das sind die schlechten Dinge
sicher, dass es dann fast überhaupt gewachsen ist
am Ende der Baustelle
wenn wir trivial genug fallen wollen
es geschah jedoch nur eine Schalung
noch Schlag auf die Schuld der Besatzung
Galerie ist niemand schuld, was das ist
passiert, er wusste, dass wir alle wissen, die
Die Arbeit bleibt am Schreibtisch
das müssen wir nicht alle
absolut alles klingt großartig
dass wir wissen, dass es Gesetze gibt